[Music]
back in 1693 the people of Salem
Massachusetts witches thought they got
rid of the senders and sisters for good
300 years later it's Halloween versus
the 20th century now they're digging up
old friends and running amok has the
power to stop them prepare to die again
you have no power before all Salem falls
under their spell
[Music]
Walt Disney Pictures presents Bette
Midler Sarah Jessica Parker and Kathy
Najimy hocus-pocus
[Music]
they love to fly and it's show
[Music]
Sparky's a great dog the great friend
the best dog okay good Hannah when you
lose someone you love they never really
leave you he'll always be in your heart
like one of them my heart I want him
here with me the nervous system is just
wires and cables even after death the
muscles respond to electricity
[Music]
[Music]
sorry boy I can fix it Oh know what your
dog is a can't tell anyone promise
[Music]
I just want my dog back
[Music]
we can do better right glosses from your
tomb
[Music]
cool
mr. Wesker says trying to tell us
something you get that out of the litter
box oh my
I need your help I asked him first my
problem bigger yeah
he's right
you are cordially invited to the
historic
[Music]
Gracie mana
where there's room for the whole family
Oh ready here where the Evers from
everything Eva's real-estate master
Gracie wishes to discuss his affairs
over dinner
this house has a bit of history to it
and this history haunts these walls I
don't think it's a good idea to put that
information on listing people love
bathrooms we should play up the whole
toilet angle I think that'd be best from
Walt Disney Pictures what happened here
mr. Gracie
do you believe in ghosts oh no clue from
the past she looks like mom that's
interesting
no message from the future i am madame
leota
seer of all that's great what is that
can prepare you for an adventure fine
the key that must be found that was easy
from the beyond
rather stand
Oh
get ready for the ride
Eddie Murphy correct spirits from the
grave come forth don't you make no dark
spirits come out while I'm sitting away
- I'll leave before dark spirits come
out the haunted mansion welcome to an
extraordinary world filled with magic
and wonder open your mind and let
yourself go a place where every day is
Halloween and every night Jack
Skellington dreams of something
different
[Music]
what's this what's this is covered
everywhere what's this haven't you heard
of peace on earth and goodwill toward
men touchstone pictures presents the
enchanting story of two very special
dreamers and the holiday spirit that
brought them together from the
imagination of Tim Burton comes The
Nightmare Before Christmas and what did
Santa bring you honey
[Applause]
[Music]
mom are you positive that there weren't
any other places looking for Vice
Principals you promised you could be
shot I promise and I looked into it
legally I can't live on my own until I'm
18 so you're the new neighbor yeah
I'm Zach by the way I'm Hannah get away
from the window now I gotta go
hi hey we're just moving in you see that
fence uh yes they on your side of it
he's a big teddy bear don't take it
personally it doesn't really like anyone
yeah
Hannah's in trouble Oh who's Hannah
she's locked in this house and her dad's
a psychopath
does she have a friend
[Music]
whoa The Abominable Snowman of Pasadena
these are all goosebumps manuscripts why
are these books locked did you unlock a
book oh no sorry I'll put it back where
it belongs
[Music]
every monster I've ever created back
into the book weaknesses the only ones
who can do this fillings I have a ton of
cavities when I was 10 I didn't brush my
teeth for a whole year when anything you
can - buried here the doors we cannot
let the monsters inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on scaredy-cat
[Music]
No maybe they're friendly Coraline Jones
always dreamed of finding a better world
a world more exciting than this
but never did she imagined that she
discovered
in her own home
[Music]
a parallel place we've been waiting for
you
Coraline where parents are always fun
and everything is so good it just can't
be real mom you're just in time for
supper dear you're not my mother my
mother doesn't yeah but the booboo
buttons do you like them
I'm your other mother silly you probably
think this world is a dream come true
[Music]
you do like it here don't you Coraline
you could stay here forever there's one
tiny little thing we need to do black is
traditional she's got this any world
where everything's better but it's all
the trip you may come out when you've
learned to be a loving daughter
from Henry Selick the director of The
Nightmare Before Christmas comes a world
of extraordinary imagination
[Music]
spooky secrets war you you're in
terrible danger girl
and daring discoveries we still have to
find my parents to set them free this
year when adventure comes knocking there
are some doors that should never be open
Alai written for the screen and directed
by Henry Selick presented in RealD 3d
[Music]
for 100 years
he has wandered the halls of Whipstaff
Manor
waiting for someone girl oh my yes
[Music]
now life every Whipstaff Manor ghosts
can't hurt you don't come near me your
spotless
the parties are always pretty to get
them
don't we have company
well company loves misery
get a grade
[Music]
take your pants before they pull you
better disgusting and now she's Creek
Universal Pictures and Edwin
entertainment are weak carrier why
invite you on a wild wondrous ride to
the other side
[Music]
[Music]
Smila Graham
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
meet Norma
can't you be like other kids your age
his parents don't get it he's probably
up there fiddling with this we jaw or is
or bury his sister doesn't like him and
the kids at school normal always pick on
him but he does have some friends yeah
man wait up I like to be alone suta why
let's do it together it's just that most
of them good morning aren't exactly
alive you see ghosts like all the time
who's a good boy that's not his chin
[Music]
from the makers of Coraline the witch's
ghost is going to wake up
you've gotta use your gift of talking to
the dead stop this is crazy do I look
crazy to you
you are I want to give that a few
minutes now to save his time oh yeah
this is getting completely
is everyone all right nobody got bitten
a bit this summer
you don't become a hero there's nothing
wrong with being scared Norman you don't
let it change who you are
paranormal marquee from the director of
pee-wee's big adventure Adam and Barbara
are ghosts what's the good of being a
ghost if you can't frighten people away
their house is being haunted by the
living maybe the house could use a and
they can't scare them into leaving it's
a little late to be neurotic so they're
calling on Betelgeuse there's no Hardin
there he goes you don't want his help
can you be scary what do you think of
this no the party's over you want
somebody out of the house I want to get
somebody out here
but the fun has just begun It's Showtime
or your boys who your friend [ __ ]
party
[Music]
is amazing
[Music]
want a cigarette thank you
[Music]
here I come live he's guaranteed to put
some life attention Kmart shoppers in
your afterlife Michael Keaton is
Beetlejuice and the ghost
[Music]
we know their stories
we fear their names
we're about to discover
where they go to rest in peace
do not disturb your eminence my
cleanness relax
welcome to Hotel Transylvania it's a
place I built for all those monsters
hiding on the persecution of humankind a
place of relaxation and tranquility what
is this place
just a normal hotel nothing going on
here my mistake what is wrong with you
people
[Music]